hey guys my name is Jess mcdonald and it
is top five time which means you no
longer need to worry about poor news
days because today everything is awesome
news let's make our way from beer to
bioware the founder of EA has a problem
with VR and it's beer related obviously
they are skeptics and the EA founder
with a soap opera named trip hawkins
says he doesn't like the idea of being
forced to wear goggles that disconnect
him from the physical world Porkins is
concerned with the ramifications of for
example as I'm in my home playing games
I don't want to knock my beer over I
don't want to not be able to find my
phone if it rings I don't want to not be
able to make eye contact with other
people in the room you know Hawkins is
hardly the first games personality to
doubt the popularity of the technology
but let me know if you're concerned over
there related incidents with VR doom
created John Romero says the consoles
are in trouble because they can't keep
up with PC and free-to-play is the
future he pointed out the games on PC
tend to be cheaper and the hardware is
always evolving giving it the upper hand
as far as free-to-play goes he reckons
that the system could work quite well
but it has to be designed a bright way
he suggested the 90s shareware model
which he used on doom where gamers are
given the first chapter free and then
can pay for the rest if they enjoyed it
Romero believes devs are getting better
implementing fair and reasonable
free-to-play systems and the gamers will
inevitably come around to it
this week EA announced their new
subscription service for Xbox one and
while Sony decided to take a pass on it
it will be landing on Microsoft's
console survive bucks a month EA is
giving you access to a vault of their
games ten percent off digital content
through xbox one and the chance to play
trial versions of upcoming EA titles up
to five days early now whether or not
this is good value is your call Sony
decided to opt out of the office citing
poor value and likely because it
competes with their PlayStation Plus and
PlayStation L programs the later of EA
access is now out and the game is
presently featured on it are fifa 14
madden NFL 25 peggle two and battlefield
4 eurogamer's digital foundry has
analyzed the last of us on ps4 to see
how its improved on the original as well
as how it's been held back by its ps3
origins the 1080p 60 frames per second
remaster certainly has a lot going for
it graphically and functionality wise
but as digital foundries Richard
ledbetter explains what Naughty Dog has
done is to scale up both physical and
temporal resolution but the core
technologies are very much ps3 in nature
the mind bogglingly good anti-aliasing
seen in the uncharted 4 teaser isn't
here for example instead it's a
reasonable enough post-process effect he
went on to note that the lighting is a
tad lackluster and although textures
look lovely geometry remains the same
regardless the improvement to detail
view distances and overall precision
have done a lot for the last gen title
and evidently by where is not interested
in whether or not I yep asleep again
since they've been releasing some super
creepy trailers for their new project in
one trailer a dude is pursued by a dark
figure and in the second a whole other
dude has his phone blown up by a dark
figure and then his phone literally
blows up both trailers point to a
website called you've been chosen which
reads they are watching your power is
rising Cologne Germany you've been
chosen presumably cologne is referring
to gamescom where the con is taking
place so it's likely we'll hear more
about bioware's project in a couple of
weeks ask you a question of the day let
me know if you're keen for bioware's new
project and what you think it might be
about this week on site check out why
I'm obsessed with the walking dead Danny
chats to death of the demo and Skyrim
mod seems to flying cheese those are all
the good things I wanted to tell you
about this week I'll be back on Monday
with more news goodness but have a great
weekend till then